he hecho varios vídeos sobre inflación y
deflación y como estos pueden ser
impactados por la utilización de la
capacidad y la noción tradicional sobre
la utilización de la capacidad y es al
menos lo que entiende mi mente cuando
alguien menciona este término es la
utilización de capacidad industrial yo
me imagino fábricas y cuando alguien
dice baja utilización
me imagino fábricas que no están
trabajando que están casi casi
abandonadas y cuando mencionan gran
utilización me imagino fábricas que
están trabajando a triple turno diario
sin embargo en una economía basada en el
servicio como la que se tiene en eeuu y
en otras sociedades occidentales la
mayoría de la capacidad real de lo que
se produce o producto interno bruto es
basado en el servicio esta es una
economía basada en el servicio y si
ustedes piensan en ello la capacidad
industrial es importante pero es más
importante para una economía basada en
la manufactura en una economía basada en
el servicio la mejor medida de
utilización realmente
es el desempleo mejor dicho la mejor
medida de la falta de utilización es el
desempleo y ya ha dicho esto me parece
que es muy importante tener un
conocimiento o una comprensión más
profunda sobre cómo se mide el desempleo
al menos como lo mide el gobierno y
también sobre la terminología que
escuchamos en los noticieros qué es lo
que significan realmente todas estas
gráficas que les voy a mostrar las
obtuve del sitio de material block que
tiene un blog llamado el análisis
económico global y hace poco conversé
con él y me señaló bastantes cosas
interesantes que quiero compartir con
ustedes para poder tener una comprensión
mejor sobre el desempleo y comprender
las pistas de qué es lo que está pasando
en este momento los invito a que lean su
blog que está en inglés lo pueden
encontrar como me pueden buscar en
google la palabra m&s h y seguro les va
a aparecer en primer lugar su blog él
hace muchos análisis económicos en donde
revisen la información disponible pero
la analiza a bastante profundidad mucho
más de lo que nos explican en televisión
realmente eso es lo que se tiene que
hacer para poder comprender cabalmente
lo que sucede y aquí quiero darle
crédito total ya que él fue quien me
señaló todos estos elementos que son muy
útiles para comprender la utilización de
la capacidad y también para la inflación
y deflación aquí tengo una imagen de
pantalla de las estadísticas de la
oficina de empleo lo que la mayoría de
las personas no se dan cuenta es que así
como tenemos en la oferta monetaria
diferentes mediciones o medidas también
se tienen diferentes medidas con
respecto al desempleo y los números que
ustedes escuchen que se reportan al
menos desde 1994 es 3 y aquí vamos a
comenzar es la tasa oficial de desempleo
13 nos dice que el desempleo total como
porcentaje de la fuerza laboral civil la
tasa de desempleo oficial aquí es
importante darnos cuenta de a qué se le
considera desempleo como porcentaje de
la fuerza laboral civil se le considera
desempleado a aquellas personas que no
tienen trabajo y que han estado buscando
trabajo han buscado trabajo en las
últimas cuatro semanas buscado trabajo
en las últimas cuatro semanas
esto es algo importante al menos
relacionado con todo lo demás que
veremos en este vídeo todos sabemos y
quizás todos hayamos tenido algún
momento en nuestras vidas en el que nos
consideramos desempleados o consideramos
que alguien es desempleado quizás los
corrieron han dejado de buscar empleo
quizás los rechazaron y quieren tomar un
descanso pero lo que no nos hemos dado
cuenta es que los números que escuchamos
del gobierno no toman en cuenta estos
como fuerza laboral si ustedes están
buscando trabajo lo han estado buscando
durante las últimas cuatro semanas y
después dejaron de buscarlo porque no lo
encontraban a lo mejor se tomaron otra
semana extra para mejorar su currículum
y poder volver a aplicar para otros
trabajos más adelante el gobierno ya no
los considera usted es parte de la
fuerza laboral civil y no se les va a
incluir en este número tienen otros
números que comprenden otros aspectos
más amplios los cuales son importantes y
de hecho vamos a ver la diferencia entre
estos cuatro es el desempleo total más
trabajadores desmotivados como
porcentaje de la fuerza de laboral civil
más trabajadores desmotivados
así que agregamos a los trabajadores
desmotivados en el numerador antes en 3
teníamos a los desempleados que voy a
poner como un sobre los empleados más
los desempleados y recordamos que un
desempleado aquí es alguien que no tiene
trabajo pero que lo ha estado buscando
durante las últimas cuatro semanas en
cambio cuatro es esto mismo desempleado
más desmotivados sobre empleados más
desempleados más desmotivados y la
definición que ellos tienen sobre
trabajadores desmotivados se refiere a
las personas que han dejado de buscar
trabajo activamente después de cuatro
semanas y se considera desmotivado
siempre y cuando se dé una razón
económica de por qué se dejó de buscar
trabajo pueden decir es que ya no hay
trabajos para lo que yo hago y es ahí
cuando se le incluye a uno en este
número 15 es exactamente lo mismo pero
lo que hacen es agregar a todos los
trabajadores adjuntos marginados
la diferencia entre un trabajador
desmotivado y trabajadores adjuntos
marginados es que el trabajador
desmotivado va a dar la razón económica
por la que está desmotivado dicen yo
dejé de buscar empleo desde hace cuatro
semanas porque me es imposible encontrar
el empleo que yo estoy buscando no
encuentro trabajo como contador o como
ingeniero mientras que un trabajador
adjunto marginado también dice bueno ya
no he buscado trabajo en las últimas
cuatro semanas pero no dan estas razones
de que la economía es lo que está siendo
imposible que ellos encuentren trabajo
podría ser que ellos se encuentren
deprimidos en general y bueno puede
haber muchísimas razones lo importante
aquí es que en la encuesta que la
oficina de estadísticas laborales
realiza esas personas no ofrecen un
argumento de la razón por la que ya no
buscan trabajo es por cuestiones
económicas si no ponen una razón
económica entonces se los considera como
trabajadores adjuntos marginados no como
desmotivados o seis es realmente
interesante ya que incluye todos los
anteriores pero desplaza a algunas
personas así que
aquí agregaríamos los trabajadores
marginados arriba y abajo en un 6
tenemos desempleo total más todos los
trabajadores adjuntos marginados más la
reserva económica de los empleados de
tiempo parcial como un porcentaje de la
fuerza laboral civil más todos los
trabajadores adjuntos marginados aquí lo
importante es que se incluye a los
empleados de tiempo parcial así que aquí
el denominador no cambia pero este
número de desempleo va a aumentar va a
ser más grande ya que una parte de la
población empleada que no están
trabajando a jornada completa no
trabajan tanto como ellos quisieran o
que ni siquiera trabajan en el campo en
el que ellos quieren trabajar quizás en
lugar de trabajar como ingeniero tienen
que trabajar 24 horas a la semana en la
librería local o cafetería estas
personas están incluidas en un 6 y la
razón por la que quiero resaltar esto y
por la que mis me indicó su importancia
es porque esto está aumentando mucho más
rápido que esto otro hay que pensar por
qué está sucediendo esto y ver a qué
conclusiones podemos llegar lo que él
hizo y esos números se tomaron
directamente de la oficina de
estadísticas laborales pero
y vemos a marzo de 2008 el número tres
fue 5.2 por ciento y el número 16 fue de
9.3 la diferencia entre estos dos es de
4.1 pero si vamos al mes más reciente el
número de desempleo total es 8.5 pero el
número 16 el que incluye los
trabajadores desmotivados a los adjuntos
marginados y a las personas que no están
trabajando tiempo completo por razones
económicas la diferencia es de 7.1 por
ciento así pues las personas que
quisieran trabajar pero dejaron de
buscar trabajo porque fueron rechazados
o que tomaron un trabajo que de otra
forma no lo hubieran aceptado esa parte
está aumentando y la razón por la que
queremos enfocarnos en esto es que nos
dice que aún cuando la tasa de desempleo
o la tasa oficial de desempleo que está
aumentando rápidamente esta gráfica que
hizo me muestra que la diferencia entre
un 3 y un 6 se ha estado incrementando y
se incrementa una tasa acelerada al
menos desde el último mes de febrero que
se muestra justo aquí en esta gráfica y
esto
lo obtuvo de su amigo chris lava así que
le damos el crédito total de esto aquí
tenemos a use la medida de desempleo que
contempla más casos esta se está
incrementando a una tasa mucho mayor que
la medida de desempleo estándar atrás y
esta línea verde de aquí abajo es la
diferencia entre estas dos lo
interesante de esto es que está
representando el porcentaje del conjunto
laboral que está siendo rechazado que
está siendo deprimido ya sea que sean
rechazados o hayan dejado de buscar
empleo o dicen bueno ya no puedo tener
un trabajo de tiempo completo en mi
profesión tendré que ir a trabajar a la
tiene departamental local o hacer lo
necesario para poner comida en la mesa
de la familia así que en general este es
el nivel de desesperación y si ven aquí
lo cual es bastante interesante esta
gráfica también es de chris wood lava
miremos esto con relación al pasado la
última gran recesión de la que habla la
gente es en la década de 1980 la
recesión de doble fondo
aquí la tasa de desempleo oficial está
indicada en azul esto
bastante por debajo si vemos este punto
se encontrarán más o menos por encima
del 10% aún cuando son mucho más
pequeñas en ese entonces que ahora aquí
estamos en el 8.3 si vemos a un 6 que es
la más general está aumento y
desafortunadamente no se tiene
información de un 6 antes de 1994 en
donde se hicieron cambios en la forma de
la medición ya que en ese entonces la
tasa de desempleo oficial se llamaba 5 y
no 3 aunque en su mayor parte era la
misma medida pero un 6 no existía para
nada antes de 1994 por lo que
desafortunadamente no podemos tener
información de esta tasa antes de esta
fecha pero un buen pseudo indicador para
el 6 del que sí tenemos información
histórica es el número de desempleados
por más de 15 semanas estas son personas
que han estado buscando empleo pero 15
semanas después aún no encuentran
trabajo aún cuando han estado buscando
trabajo activamente y eso si lo
comparamos con las medidas que tenemos
de uséis arrastrado esa medida bastante
bien
así que si hacemos la suposición de que
uséis siempre estará en esa línea o más
arriba como se muestra en la gráfica de
aquí entonces un 6 a principio de la
década de 1980 estaba probablemente
donde ahora se encuentra esa línea
quizás un poquito más arriba pero lo que
nos muestra esta gráfica realmente es
que esta medida más amplia de desempleo
de hecho es tan mala como lo fue a
principios de la década de 1980 aunque
no tenemos esa información de esa fecha
y aún esos empleados de tiempo parcial
aún cuando tienen empleo y no aparecen
oficialmente como desempleados hacen que
este número se vea un poquito mejor pero
aquí tenemos menos personas ya sea
empleadas o desempleadas si están
empleadas harán que este número se vea
un poquito más grande aquí tenemos más
personas que se cuentan el número de
empleados por lo que hacen que la tasa
oficial de desempleo se vea un poquito
más pequeña a comparación de la realidad
económica y eso es algo importante para
darse cuenta tenemos esta tasa de
desesperación acelerada en la economía y
esto nos dice que las cosas están
empeorando y que probablemente son tan
malas
como lo fueron en las peores recesiones
de la historia de eeuu y esto solo está
empeorando si regresamos a lo que
comentamos al inicio de este vídeo en
relación a la utilización de la
capacidad y lo que esto hace a los
precios eso nos dice que la utilización
laboral
es baja y sigue bajando es decir que el
precio del trabajo está bajando
seguramente ustedes ya han leído algunas
noticias al respecto en donde los
empleados están teniendo recortes de
sueldo y esto ya nos está mostrando una
deflación en los salarios y si estamos
viendo deflación en los salarios es un
punto de información que nos indica que
al menos al mediano plazo se seguirá
viendo una continua deflación en los
precios generales nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo